From characters surviving fatal
wounds to zombies with super speed,
there are still some aspects of
"The Walking Dead" that simply
can't be explained. Here are just some of the
strange inconsistencies and giant plot holes.
In the very first episode, Rick Grimes
awakes from a coma to find himself in
the middle of a zombie apocalypse. While this
certainly makes for a dramatic series kickoff,
it's never made clear how Rick managed to survive
up to that point. Prior to the apocalypse,
Rick was a sheriff's deputy. He sustained a
gunshot wound in the line of duty, which put
him in a coma for four to five weeks, according
to "Walking Dead" showrunner Dave Erickson.
That's a lot of time to be in a coma without
medical attention. In the web series, "The Oath",
we learn that a doctor stayed at the
hospital after the outbreak and took
care of the patients for a while.
"My oath is to people who need help,
and that holds up now, more than ever."
This helps explain how Rick survived, but
he still wakes up alone and malnourished,
which implies that he's been without
medical care for a while. It must be magic.
The outbreak happens on August 26, 2010,
yet Rick and the gang somehow find a 2011
Hyundai Tucson in Season 2. This means that
the group found a vehicle that wasn't
invented yet, let alone mass-produced.
They drive the kiwi green SUV around for two
seasons, using it to escape from hordes of
zombies, but it never gets a dent or a
speck of blood on it. The vehicle stays
sparkling clean in a post-apocalyptic world
because of a product placement deal with
Hyundai. The contract stated that the vehicle
couldn't break down, get excessively dirty,
or be used to run over zombies. While this makes
sense for Hyundai, the pristine car looks out
of place in the world of the show. But hey, if
we were living in a post-apocalyptic world and
found a time-traveling car that was always clean
and never broke down, we'd drive it around, too.
Rick and the rest of the survivors are in
Georgia for most of the series. Georgia
summers are hot and humid, but it gets
cold and snows during winter. Despite this,
we hardly ever see the survivors
deal with snow in "The Walking Dead".
In fact, there isn't a single
snowflake until the Season 9 finale.
"The best bet is to go old
school to keep toasty. I'd
advise initiating Winter I - Ice Storm Protocol."
In 2022, showrunner Angela Kang told CinemaBlend,
"One of the things we were trying to do
this season is play with the rhythm of
the storytelling a little bit, and hopefully
do some things that we hadn't done before."
Between fending off walkers and hostile groups of
people, the characters already have a lot to deal
with, but seeing them brave the elements upped
the ante even more. Since snowfall only adds to
the drama, it's interesting that so little
of the show takes place during wintertime.
In Season 8, Negan devises a plan for his
group to smear zombie guts on their weapons,
infecting anyone unlucky
enough to be attacked by them.
"Hilltop is gonna learn to tow the line,
one way or another, dead or alive."
It sounds like a pretty good plan — except that it
reveals a huge plot hole about whether
or not zombie blood can infect people.
If survivors get infected every time zombie
DNA enters their bloodstream, there are several
instances in which characters should've gotten
infected, but somehow don't. In Season 2, Episode
10, "18 Miles Out", Shane gets trapped in a school
bus while fighting walkers. He cuts his hand with
a dirty knife and uses his blood to distract them.
In Season 7, Episode 10, "New Best Friends", Rick
goes up against a walker with spikes coming out of
its body. His hand gets cut by one of the blades,
which we can assume is covered in infected
blood since it's impaling the zombie's body.
So which is it? Can zombie
blood infect survivors or not?
"You all submit to a blood test.
That's the price of admission."
If not, Negan's plan makes no sense. And
another thing: why haven't survivors smeared
zombie goo on themselves more often to
avoid danger? They use this tactic to
camouflage themselves in Seasons 1 and 5.
And of course, there are the Whisperers,
who regularly wear zombie faces to
blend in with herds of the undead.
From the group's invincible Hyundai Tucson to
Daryl's iconic motorcycle, the survivors use
a variety of vehicles throughout the show. But
the story takes place over a number of years,
and gasoline has an expiration date,
so where is this magic gas coming from?
RAC Limited, a British
automotive services company,
confirmed this information in 2019, saying,
"Generally speaking, petrol has a shelf-life of
six months if stored in a sealed container at
20 degrees [Celsius] — or just three
months if kept at 30 degrees. Once
you've put fuel in a jerry can or other
containers, you only have a few months
before the quality starts to fall away —
even less if the fuel is contaminated."
They go on to explain that using old gasoline
can damage vehicles and impact their overall
performance. However, this isn't the only reason
why characters shouldn't be able to drive in
the show. Think about how much maintenance
vehicles require on a regular basis. Flat tires,
dead batteries, and transmission problems
are pretty common problems even during a
non-apocalypse. When you consider that
most of the vehicles in the show have
been sitting unattended for months or years
on end, and not every group has a mechanic,
watching the survivors cruise
around at will just doesn't add up.
Survivors in a post-apocalyptic world would
have way more to worry about than landscaping,
so why are there freshly mowed lawns
in the show? The prison that Rick
and the gang discover in Season 3
has a large, well-maintained yard,
despite no one taking care of it. There are
some prisoners there when the group arrives,
but they've been locked in the cafeteria for
months, so they didn't have access to the lawn.
Was there a zombie landscaper
that still had the basic motor
skills to push a lawnmower across
the field? Before the show aired,
AMC released some rules that all zombies in
the show follow, which included this one:
"Zombies are not dexterous.
They cannot pick up or use
any items more complex than a rock or a stick."
So no weed-whackers, then.
During an interview with Chris
Hardwick in 2017, showrunner Scott
M. Gimple finally addressed this enigma:
"I am working on a story. All of these years,
why the grass is cut will be
answered. [...] It will be told."
It seems like it'd be hard to carve out "me
time" in the middle of a zombie apocalypse,
yet, between making supply runs and fighting for
their lives, the survivors manage to maintain
stylish haircuts. Carol, for example, rocks a
pixie cut and Negan shaves the sides of his head.
For the most part, the men do a great job
grooming their facial hair, whether they're
sporting a majestic, well-moisturized beard or
just the right amount of stubble. But the ladies
of the show stay especially well-groomed. In
addition to keeping their eyebrows on point,
there aren't any hairy legs or
armpits in sight. Their smooth,
radiant skin hints at a 10-step nightly routine
and an effortless "no makeup" makeup look.
No matter how dire the situation, all
of the survivors have stylish clothes
that fit them perfectly. Yes, they're a
bit dirty and have some holes in them,
but that kind of wear and tear could
happen over the course of a week-long
camping trip. And can we talk about how
great everyone's teeth look? Maybe there
were salons and dentists in Alexandria, but
the rest of the time? It doesn't make sense.
There are many different types of walkers in
the show, from those that couldn't move around,
to those that wandered back home, and everything
in between. But, despite all the zombie variants,
zombie children are weirdly missing
from the series for the most part.
Ironically, the first zombie that ever appears
on the show is a little girl. In the very first
episode, Rick tries talking to her, but
then she starts getting aggressive and he
has to shoot her. After that, there
are a handful of other zombie kids,
such as Carol's daughter Sophia, the Governor's
daughter Penny, and Noah's unnamed brother.
However, that's nothing compared
to the hordes of adult zombies that
threaten the survivors at every turn. The
scarcity of zombie children is unusual,
especially considering that in
the "Walking Dead" universe,
everyone has the virus and turns into a zombie
after they die, whether or not they're bitten.
The survivors face all kinds of
danger throughout the series,
including the possibility of starvation. At
the beginning of Season 3, the group has been
on the run for a while and Carl is so hungry
that he almost resorts to eating canned dog
food. There have even been episodes when the
group has to walk miles on end, like when they
are trying to find Terminus in Season 4, but all
that extra cardio doesn't lead to any weight loss.
When it comes to body weight, viewers have had
questions about two characters in particular:
Tara and Eugene. In a 2016 Instagram
post, Alanna Masterson, who played Tara,
fired back at body shamers and explained
that she'd just had a baby before filming
Season 7. Josh McDermitt, who played
Eugene, addressed his own character's
appearance during an interview with
Entertainment Weekly in 2018, saying,
"It's hard to go from one
week to the next and you go,
'Well, it would be awesome if I was 30 pounds
lighter.' [...] That's physically impossible."
No one is saying that actors should be body
shamed or pressured to lose weight. However,
when the story of the show involves extremely
meager rations and grueling journeys on foot, a
little makeup or CGI to temporarily slim down the
characters would make things much more realistic.
Is Rick immortal? He's survived the bleakest of
situations, like the bridge incident in Season 9,
Episode 5, "What Comes After". He's bleeding
heavily after being thrown off his horse and
impaled by a rebar in the previous episode.
Fading in and out of consciousness, he leads a
huge herd of walkers to a bridge and sets off an
explosion to protect the rest of the survivors.
But he's on the bridge with the herd when this
happens, so his friends and family assume he died
in the explosion. We later learn that Rick somehow
survived the blast, fell into the zombie-infested
river below, and washed up on shore without
drowning, getting bitten, or losing a critical
amount of blood. We get that the writers didn't
want to kill Rick off since he's the main
character, but it's ridiculous how many injuries
this man can recover from. Any side character
would've died as soon as they fell onto the rebar,
or at the very latest, during the explosion.
Most of the walkers in the show are weak,
slow, unintelligent, and uncoordinated,
especially compared to the zombies in
franchises like "28 Days Later". Despite this,
there are many instances when the zombies
act differently than usual. Some of them are
strong enough to single-handedly crack glass,
break through walls, or drag a grown man away.
When it comes to speed, AMC's rules for
the show state that zombies can't sprint;
the fastest they can move is a, quote,
"shambling run." In addition, they explain that:
"The ability to run is based on
the amount of time a zombie has
been undead, and how much decay has set in."
However, there have been times when walkers keep
pace with characters running at full speed. One
glaring example of this is in the Season
2 premiere, "What Lies Ahead," when Sophia
is running for her life and two walkers
are able to keep up with her just fine.
And what about the zombies' varying levels of
intelligence and dexterity? In the show's first
episode, a zombie returns home and tries
to open the door. In the next episode,
a zombie chasing after Rick and Glenn has
the wherewithal to climb over a chain link
fence without breaking its legs. These
instances are a far cry from walkers
mindlessly stumbling around all day.
Do we chalk it up to undead evolution?